[Music]
you start doing this do this down you
ready
if I say David calls me Oliver it's
obvious the prettiest Road is here
I got ya I'm coming you're making a long
way around but we're talking about
centimeters no lenses so if you watch me
slightly if I do this I start coming out
here
he's coming where there sees get your
mind partly that's no good maybe it's
not me going inside here because these
are he's then what I do is I've got
besides we've got our second half
who huge her wing muscles I've got you
I actually think our eyeliner where he
is not very much but to do that I've got
to do a very tight turn because all be
punished
I don't beat his turn and they had that
two attacks against no choice I type
what and then if I do it and the one you
know when I got out of here
this is something you counties but prior
to today's how top do you make your
movements help small you make the
movements without moving without an
action being being seen an action being
seen these are actions that every deceit
you just got you got quite tired
all that strong establishment way so
what you're told is you're trying to do
maximum in women spice you do that and
you've got many arms as so many things
[Music]
this is really as they be known of the
candidates I become so here because you
can't get weather but it's the surprise
of intent come to here and you and you
then return what happens is the action
is itself those URL because the way it
is body
you keep is earning the sequence of
includes me you correctly this man have
to punch your hips in a confined space
if you try to stare
they're bulky but so this is a very
powerful guided one say I'm working in
those fights easy maxing hips and then
you can stop because you may learn power
control you have to swing the job
even that reacts exist for trust the
data cache for eternity the point is
really strong different thing what are
they wrong
in fact I start with here service
amenities that we have you can twist
this restricted for instance
[Music]